did you see the plus minus on which
states lost the most people during
pandemic i saw it and which states
gained the most can you pull up that
chart real quick
uh so if you look at this here this is
during the pandemic who gained the most
and who lost the most okay david if he
can uh switch back on this okay so at
the top
not surprised florida first place
biggest plus minus oh we know we feel
the pricing
221 000 people moved to florida plus
minus during covid
then it's texas plus 170 did it's
arizona leaving california to arizona
93.
carolina's 88 south carolina 64.
tennessee 61 lowest tax rate in america
all in is tennessee and it's georgia
idaho and uh utah nevada oklahoma
alabama montana
then it's by the way in montana while
i'm there everybody know what everybody
was talking about how many people are
moving here left and right i'm like
montana yeah you would be amazed how
many people are moving to montana that's
what they were talking about sky country
arkansas maine missouri anyway so you
get that list right there the plus minus
now look at the minus all the way at the
bottom california they lost 367
yeah people and their policies are just
getting worse they're not getting better
it's not like they're changing their
policies they're just getting worse then
it's new york it's a tight race
on where that's at then it's illinois so
i'm one that left california illinois is
where matt and sheena they left illinois
to go to dallas texas
then he got massachusetts louisiana
jersey which is gerard d.c maryland
minnesota hawaii
virginia michigan dakota so red states
are gaining people blue states are
losing how do you interpret this
why don't you tell me i'll tell you what
you think about these the initial
obvious answer is like less regulation
less taxes let's get the hell out of
california overreach cover you know mass
mandates mandates mandates overreach
overreach
um which is obvious i'm sure that's part
of the reason
the other half of that how i would
interpret this
is people are getting the hell out of
cold states you can now work from
anywhere you can work remote look at all
the states in the top six or something
like this all below the sunbelt hawaii
schools
well that's a regulation
i'm looking at the top everything is
below uh the sun florida texas arizona
north carolina south carolina tennessee
georgia top seven states are basically
like let me just have some decent
weather other than california you've got
new york illinois massachusetts new
jersey d.c maryland minnesota they're
like i can't even take the freaking cold
anymore yeah i was just with my family
last night a sports agent
and they're all from minnesota they're
all like we're here in florida now
they're a minnesota family they're just
like why are we even thinking about the
cold we can work from anywhere i go when
you go back to minnesota he goes we just
booked a one-way flight to south florida
i'll go back when i need to go back i
can work from anywhere so yes regulation
yes overreach yes what do you think is
more important let me ask you a question
what do you think is more important
weather yeah lifestyle
or regulation i think they're all
equally important you think so 100 you
think so cuba's got great weather
just so you know cuba cuba's got great
weather
you know great weather great
you're telling me all of it is important
dude let's move the podcast to cuba
i've been to cuba before i know you have
you need to go to cuba just go to little
havana miami ocho they'll take care of
you down there tell them
so what's more important think about it
as a human being what is more important
to you you okay you think lifestyle is
over regulation and control that's not
what people are telling you the last 18
months it depends who you are
if you're a business owner yeah or you
have a family
100 i don't think if it's anybody if
you're just a single person you're like
dude i'm stuck in minnesota yeah i'm 27
years old i don't even make 40 grand a
year i'm going to freaking florida yeah
i don't i don't even think i didn't i
think period tico doesn't like too much
regulation what are you talking about
guys nine years old i want to read
another book
you're gonna read boy i can't do
anything about reading anymore he's
addicted to it but the point is what are
you saying all i'm saying to you is
freedom is valuable people want to be
left alone to be able to make their own
decisions with their lives they don't
like force and anywhere where there's
too much
force and regulation people want to get
out this data says a lot but i'm telling
you right now i'm telling you right now
that number in the bottom new york and
california is just getting warmed up
there this is not like the peak
they're just getting started why don't
we do a poll
what do you want to ask our audience
yeah what do you want you're gonna move
why would you move taxes regulation or
lifestyle that's a good question if you
move why would you move yeah why would
you move that's like if you're in new
jersey are you moving because of taxes
regulation overreach
or is it or is it
lifestyle hey you did a video of you on
an icy ass plane in montana you pull up
that video okay and then you're like
five minutes later you're in florida
dude pull up that video real quick about
uh montana we literally got stuck in a
blizzard
we got stuck in here ashley graham by
the way
make that bigger can you make that
bigger
yeah this is what it looked like in
montana two days ago
it can change very quickly this is up in
montana [ __ ] a blizzard
it's one degree this is saturday
four miles later here's what it looks
like in florida
no craziness no madness exactly
yeah
sometimes you just got to be patient
and weather the storm
life okay well
you're kind of proving my point here but
wait a minute so so so then here's a
question for you why is montana on the
plus list when it's got such a small
population you're proving my points here
stop it with this send you know you're
not saying you're not miserable
my ass off so if i'm freezing my ass
have you tell me why montana's in the
top 12.
freedom baby
freedom baby okay freedom is slightly
but don't get me
wrong styles
yeah idaho lifestyle is important i
fully agree with you if i had my choice
if every one of these states were low
regulation if every one of these states
had low taxes no state tax where do you
think i'd be living right now in florida
regardless i would still be in
california california i'd be in newport
beach today yeah i would be able to hang
out with tom's entered manhattan where
do you think musk would be today what do
you think rogan would be yeah they'd be
doing they would be in california
regulations was forcing people out talia
we're going to say something so here's
the thing with california for me is is
uh half of the the taxes paid in
california are by a hundred and fifty
thousand people okay wow 150 000 people
pay half of the the taxes and the
multi-millionaires in the billionaires
where is california going to get its
money they've already lost rogan they've
lost elon musk they've lost they're
losing uh hollywood celebrities are
losing guys like you it's like they're
not going to have any money and on top
of the taxes and regulation it's the
fact that they don't have any water it's
the fact that energy costs are
outrageous you can't run a lawn mower
because it's outlawed i mean it's just
it's unreal man california is going to
is going to collapse but have you been
in california tyler unfortunately not
i'd love to go i've heard let me put it
to you beautifully i lived there for 20
plus years i freaking love california
i use san francisco one of our favorite
places to go to
santa barbara go to bacara incredible
resort to stay at san diego unfreaked
one of the best kept secrets in america
the valley pasadena oh pass colorado
palm springs
yucca valley
california has so many freaking
incredible spots ridiculous regulations
driving people out the most yesterday
i'm at louis bossie with jen and uh baby
brooklyn big cheeks
and and i'm eating and all of a sudden i
see this guy that's looking at me all
funny i thought we're about to get into
it
he's a valentine's the usual thing he
says bro
he says bro
are you kidding me he's looking at me
his wife and kids i said he said dude
his wife's like that's the guy
so i'm like who's the guy i'm holding
brooklyn i'm trying to you know uh
walker because i'm running late to a zoo
and he says you were in florida because
of your video 10 reasons why i moved to
florida he moved to florida jennifer
walks up he says do you know where
husband and wife and two kids from
uzbekistan okay who lived in new york
moved to florida because they looked at
the video and they said florida just
makes way too much sense they move over
here incredible how opportunity when you
look at something and how many other
families are sitting there saying i'm
kind of sick of it as well i want to
move as well but adam i'm telling you
right now remember when i said this to
you the statistics this is just getting
started because politics in california
and new york ain't changing anytime soon
it ain't changing anytime soon anyways
well shout out to bill de blasio i
believe is his last week in office so i
know he's done a great job you're going
to miss him you're a big fan of it i'm
not a fan but i'm excited to see what
this guy eric adams does is this san
francisco i was actually going to ask
you to pull that up
floating around
this is san francisco oh my god can you
make it bigger or no i cannot believe
that no it's instagram
of the cap san
this union square where is this one the
greatest cities in the world used to be
one of the greatest cities in the world
yeah policies can change that man the
right policies can fix that so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]